dr. Fox her L of MIT a current casbahs
fellow his imagination computation
expression lab at MIT is both in the
computer science and artificial
intelligence laboratory as well as in
the humanities and arts and social
sciences the first professor to to be
straddling those two worlds we're in an
age where we all the full range of human
activities are delivered to us through
computer systems on a daily basis
and yet it's too rare that the
engineering and the social dynamics and
the human interactions are looked at at
the same time and that's exactly what
we're going to do tonight let's have a
big round of applause for dr. Fox taro
so thank you for the gracious
introduction Michael and also thanks
everybody from the Center for that study
the behavioral sciences at cosmos for
making this possible
the organizers here at the interval as
well as a long now foundation and
finally the Annenberg foundation for
support so today I'll be talking about
this idea of coding ourselves coding
others imagining social identities
through computing so as Michael
mentioned I run the imagination
computation and expression laboratory or
ice lab at MIT and what we do is build
systems for creative expression cultural
analysis and social empowerment so these
range from interactive narrative systems
gaming systems social media systems and
mostly most importantly new forms
possibly unanticipated by any of those
so we built a wide range of types of
work I'm not going to talk about all of
these kind of systems today but I'll
show you a few highlights with a
particular focus so I also want to
mention just to give you a sense of the
scope of the work some of the kinds of
work that been doing most recently
during this year at Casa bas at Stanford
and so one area that the work is shifted
into is machine learning approaches so
artificial intelligence approaches to
better understand our identities on
computers and the relationships between
them yes so the relationships between
social networks and games the way these
systems interoperate the way in which
you to participate in a forum you have
to log in through a social networking
accounts and how all these systems begin
to connect I've also been thinking about
the impact of the work and so that's one
of one of the statements I gave at the
beginning of the year is how to take
this out into the world and be and how
the kind of impact on the communities of
interest where it could be useful and so
one of the kind of initiatives we've
been moving into is using virtual
identities in public schools to support
rodder participation in computer science
by diverse groups and seeing students
identities in the real world is
intrinsic to their identities as
practitioners of science technology
engineering and mathematics and then the
other side of it is emotion yes so
thinking about the way to bring the
affective dimensions in and so one of
the works I've been doing is a
collaboration with director Korean Ben
Khalifa that's collaborating on a
virtual reality project to engender
mutual understanding and empathy
in war starting with Gaza but he's a
renowned photojournalist and all the
major periodicals who's been in Rwanda
the Balkans and all of these areas
they're collaborating together to think
about how to engender empathy around
these topics and when the kind of common
threads in this work is the idea that
cultural values and cultural worldview
are built into all computing systems and
how can we begin to engage more diverse
cultural values and have these kinds of
systems reach their expressive potential
and potential for empowerment and so
that's one of the main topics in the
book that's has no media that I wrote
and really and although today I'll be
focusing on the issue of representation
of identity and media such as a video
game technologies especially it's really
a kind of statement more broadly about
the expressive potential of the medium
so here's a structure of the talk so
beginning just with a brief introduction
why call the book tent as no media what
is a phantasm for me the special case of
phantasms of social identity and what
we're doing about in the lab what we're
building so to begin with let's start in
the real world off the computer yes so
the idea is that when we begin to think
about identity more more broadly it's
nothing new it's not that this is an
area that has never been studied before
it's not anything that were not
accustomed to we know that there are
stereotypes that exist out there within
the world whether they're because of
issues such as a rate that race
ethnicity gender hair color could be any
sort of topic that engenders
stereotyping and these kind of topics of
the long studied in fields like a
sociology yes so they'll be eating the
boys is talking about the idea of double
consciousness right so this is where you
see yourself differently than how the
world sees you sometimes right or the
Erving Goffman and the idea of
impression management they're trying
through in a dramaturgical way think
about the way that you can manage the
way that others begin to see you and how
you might be stigmatized or not within
society but of course these kind of
identities and phenomena have entered
into some new realms and new
configurations correct
and so important new kind of questions
have emerged right so how do data
structures and algorithms you know how
does a technical system begin to
implement long existent and newly
emergent cultural phenomena so for
example the idea of categorization in
society so this is one example that
somebody wrote you know this is a system
that scrapes publicly available data and
begins to categorize people in ways that
they might not have expected to be
categorized previously when they posted
that data yes so who wants to get fired
who's hungover right so this is just
scraping there publicly available data
aggregating it and then grouping in them
into these categories right the point
being that these are algorithmically
generated categories nobody checked the
box like a friend or relationship status
right these are ones that have been
developed by the developer through the
lens of an algorithm
and here's another case yes so these are
two avatars in Second Life the virtual
world system and you'll notice that one
of the avatars here actually it looks
quite a bit more luminous in some ways
in terms of skin and the other and the
issue is that you know the default skin
of default light reflectance model is
actually not optimized for skin tone
such as this somebody you know wrote a
new light reflectance model that kind of
new shader within the system in order to
achieve this kind of a this kind of
appearance that you see in the other
image all right so the point is that
there needed to be an algorithmic
innovation here it's it's not something
that that is strictly a kind of visual
issue there is a kind of algorithmic
issue underlying it then that in fact
when you look at the striking distance
difference between the two you can begin
to say about that there's some form of
bias you know built into the system at
least in terms of appearance yes so the
question is then which of these kind of
thinkers have to say about some of these
kinds of emergent phenomena and how can
begin to think about some of these kind
of phenomena in a new way some being
long existence such as stereotyping and
some that have emerged specifically
within these these new media and then
these are exactly the kind of questions
that I'm interested in yes so you can
think about it the book is organized
into three sections subjective compute
cultural computing and critical
computing so of course subjectivity
culture and criticality being things
that competing is always associated with
in fact it's not usually right but the
idea is that my research works on
enabling us to better understand
cultural phenomena at the code level and
building computational models and
systems to analyze and simulate cultural
phenomena so you could say that the
research aims to bridge a kind of
analytical gap so as to bridge the gap
between cultural meaning and these
phenomena such as double consciousness a
sense of self impression management
stereotyping etc and the algorithms and
data structures that underlie systems
such as social networking profiles
ecommerce accounts avatars and other
forms of virtual identity so to move
towards its or towards a CRE I want to
start just with some basic intuitions
for the way that I think about this
medium the way I think about a meaning
and how its conveyed more generally so
we'll start with it with a kind of
challenging question for you which is uh
so what does this sign mean yeah so
someone said woman here all right red
someone said I saw a sign like that not
too long ago all right so yeah so it's
it's not it's not controversial you know
for many people but the question is how
do we make sense of this particular sign
and so of course we're drawing upon some
particular worldview and drawing some
kind of specific concepts from that
worldview that's being integrated with
the sensory mental image and so what I
mean by that does we have a meant a
mental image of what the science would
represent without the sensory image
that's right there in front of us and we
immediately understand that sign as
meaning something like a woman or
referring so the fact that this is a
place that women can be now you might
say well we don't all necessarily share
the same in the same worldview but
something interesting that happens here
is that even if you don't believe that
women do or should wear clothes like
this necessarily it's not the fact that
you couldn't immediately apprehend the
meaning of the sign now this sign
however is another sign that's actually
developed at Indian Institute of
Technology used in hospital systems in
India that means the exact
same thing right so you have a similar
kind of process that the meaning and
what I'm calling a phantasm for reasons
that will become clear it happens in the
same way and this is a this another sign
that's used in Oman right service we
have another sign here and so the idea
is that in fact when we begin to look at
this sign from multiple worldviews some
of the biases and the and the intrinsic
beliefs built into the original one
began to be revealed because you didn't
say to yourself was and that's what I'm
calling a phantasm because in fact it's
a kind of semi visible execution of a
worldview through the sensory mental
image that weren't countering out there
in the wild so to speak because you
could have thought that this is somebody
wearing a kilt this is somebody wearing
a cape like a PI right something like
this and in fact interestingly you know
I wrote this book back what came out in
2013 but there's actually been an ad
campaign that's all right taking
advantage of this idea recently but it
was never addressed yes so it's nice to
see these ideas yeah out there no and
this is exactly the meaning and the
other idea is that also phantasms exists
that in code world view but we can also
develop phantasms that are new ones that
are kind of empowering phantasm so some
of the some of the power of the
computational system interested in is
that of revealing phantasms also
creating new phantasms and developing
critical awareness about them now in
terms of computing of course rely upon
the same kind of ideas right so in image
like this somebody being represented on
and as a Nintendo a me character and up
through images like this a kind of more
robust representation or an image like
you like this these come from well-known
final final fantasy role-playing games
out of Japan and one of the issues that
I'm interested in though is the fact
that these kind of phantasms then
persist as people begin to use these
systems and we know a lot about the kind
of values that go away that's that lie
behind these kind of systems yeah so
this is a classic study by Kenneth and
Mamie Clarke you know started from the
40s in which African American school
children were asked famously which doll
looks like you which dog you prefer
which doll is a good dog and with a high
degree of probability you know that they
actually shows the star that you see the
kids choosing it's choosing here
sometimes I ask what it all looks nice
with all it is a good dog then which is
all looks like you and a few children
that rebelled actually I ran out of the
study
you're crying when they realize the fact
that you know there a message within
this kind of worldview yes so this and
the point here isn't just to recap the
study which is the kind of well known
study but in the book one of the things
that I do is begin to think how can we
look at these phantasms in a
semi-structured way that's useful for
thinking about computing systems and so
this is just a kind of cursory breakdown
just thinking in terms of the types of
elements the attributes and so forth
just to show that when we think about
these issues on the computer we actually
have to think about them in a way that
they're instantiated in data structures
and the way that they're that they're
implemented when you begin to have this
stall immediately apprehended as being
the nice-looking doll so why the concept
of fantazmo media to get at these kind
of a phenomena well the cognitive
science concept of the phantasm again
emphasizes the role of worldview and
values in computing systems and it can
aid in analyzing and designing computing
systems and so the book pins this down
in in all the detail with a nomenclature
and scientific and engineering that
background as well as references are to
cross the arts so so I won't focus all
the details here but I wanted to give
you a sense of what I mean when I talk
about phantasms and so in particular for
this talk although remember of phantasms
can refer like the word concept they can
refer to anything on the word sign there
could be anything that's out there in
the world but today I'll be focusing on
phantasms of identity in particular
facts has no social identity and of
course identity isn't limited just to
the normative forms of identity such as
race ethnicity gender and so forth but
also posture fashion body language right
so all the personality all these nuance
forms of identity so my question when I
started a project was called the
advanced identity representation project
it's not because the computing system is
what is I
it's in fact because the way that we
navigate this in the real world is so
advanced in nuance we begin to move from
the regular structures of the system
that to achieve and respond to some of
the kind of new wants that people have
in the real world so just to give an
example of what I mean here let's look
at one particular computer game and some
of the kind of problems with based
identity phantasms that we find so this
is a game called Elder Scrolls for
Skyrim so how many people are familiar
with with this game right yeah so I
would say about 40% of people raised
right raise their hands here and so for
those who aren't familiar but it's a
extremely popular game and this is a
narrow lens for discussing its impact
but you could think about it this way on
the on its best weekend Star Wars made 7
million dollars right so Star Wars
adjusted for inflation now I made 27
point two million dollars on its best
weekend now a Skyrim on his first day of
release adjusted for inflation so today
made 217 million dollars on the first
day right right so so again that's the
kind of narrow lens but just to give a
sense of the kind of scope of this
medium and its relationship to say but
for the film industry
so in this best-selling role-playing
game some interesting phenomena where
characters such as the Nords distensible
Norwegians or the Red Guard the
extensible African characters within the
game are subjected to a form of
stereotyping yes so just in terms of
description the Red Guards are described
basically in the essentialist stereotype
of the black athlete they're called
quote the most talented warriors in
Tamriel
the Red Guard are also physically
blessed with Hardy constitutions and
quickness of foot if they're basically
in game playing terms it translates into
bonuses to their running and jumping
ability if you be in the play throughout
throughout the game so how many people
who have played oblivion have also
played the sequel Skyrim right there so
a couple for you for here so those who
have played the sequel so this is a deep
bastard mentioned you can there's such a
fine grain of customization you can do
with these avatars this is a default
before anything has changed but you can
change the shape of the bridge of the
nose and then the flare of the nostrils
and and skin so you can change it in an
immense number of ways and so the
default Red Guard in Skyrim do you think
that the situation
changed improved so do you remember what
it looks like right yeah so it's a topic
I've been writing about for a little
while anyway the 217 million dollar the
sequel is selling sequel I mentioned
Skyrim actually the default avatar looks
like this now so before you make any
change to it so but what I would claim
is that in fact this this avatar
it's neither better nor worse right so
why is it neither better nor worse all
right well this is the reason because
this is just the front end right this is
just the graphical for a front end
there's been a number of critique notice
it's not as if it doesn't matter
particular Crofts body image and tomb
raider and this sort of thing but I'm
interested in is the back end focusing
on the values that's on the back end
data and so tell you just a little bit
about about my interest in this yeah so
when you begin to look at these
attributes for strength intelligence
willpower agility that determine your
abilities within the game so for example
your abilities to to fight or or to
exhibit stealthy behaviors or magic and
so forth well let's just take a look at
this particular road for intelligence
you notice that you happen to be in the
Norwegian the ostensibly Norwegian Nord
that I mentioned while you're 30 points
intelligence that's 20 points less
intelligent than the Breton's the
extensible French within the game the
Imperials are the Romans you know they
sort of stand in for the Romans
similarly the Red Guard are also 20
points less intelligence intelligent
than the Breton's
if your org female you're ten points
more intelligent by default than your
male counterpart right alright so you'll
have a number of these kind of values or
they're just built into the
infrastructure of the game now this can
change over time you can practice some
behaviors more than others and get
better at skills you might not be
optimized for but many players are what
are have in terms of in the literature
and game studies achiever players that
means they want to maximize all the
statistics of their character within the
game and if they play this is one of
these type of races they never can do so
but of course this is just default stats
so let's look a little bit deeper under
the hood of some of these games this is
another game called never
tonight's which is an older game and
will also a best-seller and so let's
begin to look at the data structure to
represent characters of weight within
this so there is a data structure for
race sometimes people think this is my
class you know if you look in the
technical documentation you know that
the data structures actually are called
your race phenotype and so forth and so
when you when you change the race with
it with the data about race of your
character should that impact the way
that your character looks so yeah so
some people are nodding their head so
but in fact changing the race will not
change the appearance of your character
but many items have racially based
bonuses and what about phenotype what
should that represent I'm sure you have
a number of ideas about this but
probably you didn't think that it just
determines of whether your characters of
normal shape or a larger shape what
about gender
how many genders do you think are
represented in the data structure within
this game all right so people say that
too you know sometimes people guess you
know 1 or 3 in fact it's a 5 there are
characters that are male female both
other and none although although if you
happen to it would be male both other or
none you have a male body type so 5
different genders 80% of which are male
and so these kind of issues yeah of
course they're just again like a
phantasm people are building these
systems that are based on the world
views that are out there
sometimes it's conventions are around
the medium and so what we're trying to
do is develop systems that are more
flexible in nuance in terms of how you
represent these kind of issues also
allow creative critical engagement with
them and one final thing I'll say I'll
say before going onto our systems do in
this area is that these it's not just
the kind of casual interest because most
people have some type of virtual
identity these days whether it's a
ecommerce account a social networking
profile or avatar in a virtual world or
game and these impact are real world are
rotated world engagement with each other
so we've done study say of more than
1400 people in which we found that in
using a learning game or the kind of
avatar you have actually
tax performance and engagement
significantly at Stanford where I've
been working for the year Jeremy
bailenson is a professor there who's
found it has a kind of theory called the
Proteus effect with his former student
Nikki that suggests that people change
the reward behavior based upon their
avatars behaviors so if you use an
attractive avatar you actually change
your interpersonal distance with others
in the in the real world or you might
change your exercise behavior if you
exercise within the virtual world so he
actually looks at the ways in which real
world changes to your real-world
behavior occur based on just having a
different type of avatar in a virtual
world so what we're trying to do about
it while we build two types of systems
we build systems for analysis that
that's theory to analyze phenomena
online and systems for expression new
ways to model experiences related to
identity so I'll talk just a little bit
about one of them just one of the
systems for for analysis and again we
also analyze social social networks and
so forth I'll focus just on gaming
example for continuity and so you saw
these stats from Skyrim so what we did
was perform a machine learning technique
called archetypal analysis so some of
you might be familiar with clustering
algorithms in AI that's right try to
find there's some similar
characteristics for for for different
objects within your data that could be
users and this is a little bit different
it tries to describe the data set in
terms of a set of archetypes so it's
used in sports analysis recently and so
for example in the NBA you might
characterize you might find three
archetypes rebounder a slasher and
benchwarmer right and every player can
be determined you can be described
there's some percentage of each of those
archetype statistically found within
within the data and so that's what we
did in this system and there's it's kind
of an art in a science in the sense that
you try to find this a number of
archetypes that can best describe your
data so we fed the system all the data
for the default stats according to a
race and gender within the Elder Scrolls
for oblivion we found that 3 is a good
number of archetypes to describe it if
you use too many archetypes you have
overfitting and so you're just attending
to the kind of anomalous data so we so
we found that 3 was a good number
and yeah I vote going it's all the
details so basically is using a
technique called residual sum of squares
but we were able to categorize it so
you'll see here the Nord Mail is a 97%
archetype one you know here and just
three percent archetype three the
archetypes that we found actually
correspond to well-known game the game
sort of sort of a gaming archetype so
one is physically oriented with high
strength and endurance that was a
fighter another one is the mage one has
high intelligence and and another one is
thief so high agility and the sort of
things that help you to be stealthy and
the interesting thing here so we've
plotted the red are the male characters
the back of the female characters we've
plotted them here and so you can see
that two of the three archetypes this is
a ternary plot graph yeah two of the
three archetypes here only have red dots
on them female it only fits one of the
archetypes here and the Red Guard and
Nords that you saw are clustered around
here in this physical type all right yes
so so the long and short of it and we
could analyze this more but I just
wanted to call your attention to is
first of all the statistical
distribution of stats correspond
traditional role-playing game roles
that's not surprising but just as one
example the african-american like Red
Guards are stereotyped as a physical
fighter with no characteristics of the
intelligence oriented at mage and bias
towards a male gender could be observed
because the male characters are in
general close to the archetypal ways of
playing alright so that's just one kind
of analysis we've analyzed social status
and other sort of things in social
networking sites but I just wanted to
give an example of some of the
analytical work we've also done work to
model experiences and new types in new
ways and so I'll tell you a little bit
about that these are systems for for
expression where we create our own
platforms and our own experiences using
them so first I'll talk about Jeanne
gestural narrative interaction engine
and the game called mimesis made using
it and secondly crime area which is if
you if you familiar with the idea of a
graphics engine such as unity or these
kind of systems that help with
implementing 3d graphics you could think
that crime area is the engine for
modeling social identity
so the genie platform is one that allows
for a gesture driven interaction yes so
the idea is that one way of conveying
cultural identity is through the way
that people use a gesture across
cultures and so bills touch treat
touchscreen based interactive narratives
that can say model narrative structures
model certain cinematic conventions
enable gesture input and input to drive
the story and demonstrates expressive
nonverbal interaction so I'll just give
one example of what this looks like this
isn't a fully fleshed out game but just
a demo made using it so starting from
the long shot we have a medium shot here
we have two characters that are
interacting we can interact with any
kind of objects that are on the stage
the characters have bundles of emotion
called sentiments that we've represented
both externally expressed and ones that
are only represented internally right so
it's a continuous time so it can use the
event triggers or be or be a based on
turn-taking so we have the characters
that are interacting we're showing the
passage of time here we can go to a
close-up shot and and begin to think of
a facial expression actually go into her
thought space here
I think if she's thinking about things
around the stage changing the way she
feels about those things that were on
the stage now and so when she gets back
out she's thinking about the guys have
what do you think about the Hat
and now well you don't even want to know
what I'm thinking about the Hat just now
yeah so the idea is that it's a kind of
way to drive the system where you could
imagine
rather than using a controller based
interaction in a game you can use the
kind of culturally nuanced form of
interactions such as navigating the
world in terms of your attitude your eye
rolling your body language your posture
and then so and so forth and so one of
the things we began doing was thinking
about well how could we use this to
address social different context of
social issues and so with a group of my
students we built a platform and build
one game you know with it so mimesis is
a particular game but it could be
customized differently to address issues
of everyday discrimination called the
micro aggression so what this does is
take from literature on the idea of
racial microaggressions these everyday
you know kind of covert
yeah or forms of discrimination that
usually dismissed is minimally harmful
the salsa comes out of literature in
clinical psychology so it could be micro
assaults you know sort of subtle forms
of name-calling micro insults so
ignoring somebody in a restaurant or
this sort of thing or also micro
invalidations and so you know
communications that exclude exclude
people in certain ways or nullify their
experience your reality what you think
happened that just in fact didn't happen
and so forth and to give you a sense of
these microaggressions it's a mentioned
just a few because they've been
described as falling into certain types
of themes or I read some of them you
know so for example alien in in own land
yeah so this is an example start for
example an Asian American person being
asked constantly of being told you speak
good English you know where are you from
how did you learn to speak if so so well
tell me about your culture is so exotic
you know these kind of interactions
description of intelligence maybe to the
same person you must be good at
mathematics right or you can you help me
with this problem you know or assumption
of criminal status would be another one
clutching a handbag when somebody's from
a stigmatized category and enters your
space you know this sort of thing
alright so again these are often
dismissed as minimally harmful but
clinical psychologists have found them
to be significantly detrimental to
health and happiness stress anxiety and
so forth
and they also found that there are
number of ways that people typically
respond to them well I added one which
was being oblivious but the one that
they the ones that they discuss or so
being confused you know so when somebody
asked me to move to the back of the bus
did they really mean any any anything by
it yeah or they just make you space for
some somebody else and being suspicious
that you know I should have said
something
yeah in that moment but I didn't think
of the right thing to say right there so
sort of stewing in it or being
aggressive that back in in response and
in fact that's not the case it's not the
case that any of these are always going
to be satisfactory with it within a kind
of a situation and so what we did well
you notice these octopuses and octopuses
are here so we in created a game in
which we use a mimic octopus
the type of octopus that can imitate
other creatures and model this
phenomenon of micro aggression yes sir
these sea creatures we use emotion
driven gestures to drive via the
multi-touch screen to drive the dialogue
particulars depend on the octopuses mood
and the players explore the experience
of micro aggression through this
narrative dialogue and so the endings
can change so you get depending on how
you play you could be an assimilationist
an activist and so forth and the endings
are determined based on at first we
tried to figure out a little bit if
people are aware of these experiences
your trajectory over the course of the
encounter whether you've been more open
and moved to be more closed or vice
versa are more positive and moved to be
more negative and that's within a single
encounter as well as your trajectory
across all of the encounters as well as
looking at are you are you trying to fit
in or not within the scenario so we
built a multi-touch version but we also
built a version online so I'll show the
demo video they suggested that I should
not run a system online here but it's on
our website so if you go to it I'll give
the euro at the end so you could go and
play the game up for yourself and so to
begin with
[Music]
one scenario so this is before you're
beginning to interact just to see if
you're sort of aware of this kind of
phenomena
so the jelly's says hey you come here
octopus yes what is it well you're a
genius right but that big brain of yours
to work and help me open up this
stubborn scallop I'm starving well you
know just because my cephalopod that
doesn't make me a genius it says we're
fine thanks for nothing and so that's
the end of this little scenario and so
what we do then is just ask the user a
couple of questions right so describe
the scenario you just witnessed what
would you call this type of scenario and
so forth have you experienced this type
of scenario so it's very quick actually
an early version of this we set your
initial mood based upon upon your actual
music preferences in in social network
if you like we've taken that out put it
in another system to streamline it but
the other systems are cited as well so
you have a series of interactions the
idea is to convey the systematicity of
this type of experience because just
being asked where are you from one time
right you don't know what the person's
motivation is is a discriminatory or not
but the kind of repeated encounter every
time you walk into a space you're not
from here are you know this this sort of
thing is what we want to convey and so
each feature represents a different
family of microaggression by so this is
the assumption of skill your tentacles
are so elegant
you think to yourself you have to
explain well I'm octopus and this is
sorry we don't get many of your type
around here so how do you sneak them
right and so you see you're doing it
again so now we're being positive so
positive and open is oblivia oblivia so
I don't stink I just catch my prey by
sneaking up on it interesting your
tentacles are so strange and and so
forth and so we move on to the ending of
the particular to the particular
scenario so you hope your colorful
patterns right in the water a little
that rightness may help to expand the
minds of creatures like that one and and
so moving on to there so yeah we get to
each again each feature up into
different family microaggression so here
you have alien and land in your title
zone the seahorse we don't see many
octopuses around here we're taking a
aggressive response
here's ignorant materiality of its
surroundings lived here my entire life
have you but you don't act like it
though your patterns are so lovely
they're quite exotic alright and so it
goes on like this and then finally
there's it's not a game that you win or
lose it's just mentok again can pay the
systematicity of the of the experience
and you have a kind of poetic reflection
at the very end right that's just about
the trade-off so doesn't point a finger
to you and say you are biased or not
experiences were familiar you return to
your home among the fronds and the
sunlight you feel slightly altered as
though your skin is change shape and you
have adapted it to fit it and so forth
all the way to the end you came out of
every encounter with a sense of
camaraderie since you're always able to
fit in so kind of a simulation that's
the ending and one of the ideas is that
people can then go and also if the
students can reskin this they can go in
and write a new diet and they can expand
the dialogue create new creatures if
they're interested in a more social
social realist setting your place the
occupy yeah octopuses with with
photographs and so forth so it's
extensible and so I'll conclude with
just talking about one final platform
that we created the actually mentioned
that the Genie platform that that's our
the Creative Commons
license so if people aren't just in
playing with it you could contact me
and so the crime area system is a bit
different and so I want to just give you
the sense of what it begins to model
related offense has on a social identity
and so to give you that sense imagine
you're playing a game and initially you
want to play as a knight but you're
interested in magic and begin dabbling a
little bit in magic and and have some of
the skillset of both and you realize you
don't like this or the esoteric magic
stuff and go back just a practicing
physical combat but now physical combat
has lost its luster hand so you realize
your true identity and decide to go as
they say full mage right so so imagine
another scenario you're listening your
favorite music streaming system and you
have and you listen to a strictly UK
punk rock music you decide to dab a
little bit in a bebop jazz you go back
to listening to the punk rock music and
then go full Bebop yeah as they say yeah
so the support yeah yeah so the idea is
that what's happening is there's
gradients with within categories say
moving from the margins to the center of
category and movement between categories
and that's what our platform helps to
mathematically model you know this kind
of movement between categories
categories aren't always imposed from
the top down if you have these
characteristics you're within that
category and I'm not going to depth
about the architecture suffice to say
you can create your own your own systems
with kind of your own rules that's about
different categories as well as going
outside the pulling data from LLC
elsewhere it's like going to the web and
so forth whether Rho V Corps for for a
music that's the engine behind the all
music guide or bringing in clips and
from YouTube and so forth as we built
one scenario using using the system
called a gatekeeper which model some of
the phantasms related to social
categories and so I'll tell you just a
little bit about this particular
scenario again in the chimera you could
have any number of social categories and
any number of configurations to make it
simple we started with two categories in
the and it's a kind of typical game-like
scenario we called them sylvans and rush
woods
so the sylvans are a kind of a people
within our game called gatekeeper that
love
poetry and on average and of fine
clothing and they love to speak with a
kind of elevated diction where their
brush woods on average are described
with by by other people as liking just
good hearth tales and earthy clothing
and and so forth now remember that we
separate the front end from the back
ends they could have looked like
anything they don't have to look like
elves and hobbits right right but its
spice to say that we just created two
categories for ease of of grasping the
ideas now we separate out categories and
we're calling abstract and concrete so
imagine the abstract categories that's a
social configuration you can have one
group that's considered say oppressed or
privileged you know that's or accepted
and discredited you could have a
different class structure their working
class the upper class and so forth so
you could have whatever kind of
configuration you want there and we
separate out the concrete categories and
we describe them in terms of prototypes
and so that means you could run it once
and set the brushwood to be the accepted
run it again set the the Sylvan to be
accepted have different cities or even
for different characters have different
kind of hierarchies that exist and so
and also not all brush wits have to be
the same so we have a number of features
discrete and range height speaking
ability clan gender etc and so to model
group membership you could think about
it like this
so there's only such a thing as a sylvan
a prototypical sylvan under a particular
worldview and so a prototypical sylvan
would be someone known as a tall people
on average that are judged from afar to
be lovers of finery in elaborate poetry
right so it's tagged as sylvan but has a
certain height value of let's say 70 the
same with clothing and speaking and
similarly for a prototypical brush wood
now when we implement category gradients
you can also have phenomena such as this
right so you have someone that's tagged
as a brush wood but also he'll likes the
kind of fine clothing that the sylvan do
and speaks in a way that is described on
this worldview as something like a
Sylvan what we've also implemented with
the system is what we're calling a
naturalization trajectory yeah so that
means that we can look at the change of
your membership in every category over
time over every time step and so you
could look out
movement towards the accepted category
so you see the brushwood where the the
speaking and clothing are raising past
some acceptance threshold and so that's
what do you think about it as passing
right passing as a member of a different
group here in fact we can implement a
number of times of phenomena here and so
it may be a bit small to see but these
are phenomena such as studied by Erving
Goffman I mentioned earlier stigma
allure right so where the stigmatized
category has a kind of a lure within
sort of the dominant setting dis
identifying you know that's where you
might put on a pair of glasses in order
to even though you're illiterate to seem
as if you're more literate yes so we
begin to be able to model these kinds of
phenomena say if you're looking at your
naturalization in trajectory so I
mentioned you can intentionally pass as
a member of another group all right you
could inadvertently pass as sort of luck
your way into it or not be able to do it
to do it well you could slip and not
finally pass in and so forth and so I'll
show you a little bit of the game that
uh that we created only some
participation now with a-- as well so i
described it this way right the sylvan
you know when we know what their life -
about the shogunate rush would have been
a war for ages and you know that the
sylvan are twelve people on average and
of course be in finery the brushwood are
small love earthy with fabric thinking
parties remember your sylvia helping us
build inside you stand before the aid of
a keith and you need to enter the
meeting size
so you see it rush regardless brush with
the garden where you looks curious and
so if you speak to them in your own
language you say some weather we're
having today today or feeling very well
if star shines upon your garden so
that's what you want see him he has a
very expression he said we don't see
many a new a new folk around this around
this part these part did you travel far
to get here it seemed but you say I
don't see many silver around here which
is not far from home oh yes good man
this is a strange lab to me you went
from just three on the way or I'm from a
little ways off
[Music]
in exchanging not gonna ask you two
questions but just to go through a very
quickly I want to show you there's a
kind of narrative structure you hear
that actually 1530 linguistics we're in
entrance clauses they have different
kinds of didn't so there was a test here
your category membership yeah so there
are a number of different kind of
endings you have green and and pink here
you can get in or not get in that's what
those represent but we have different
kind of themes like acceptance denial of
self stigma allure failure yeah failure
to access and and so and so forth and so
just to give you an example he's so
acceptance so you do everything that he
likes you could get well thankfully I
was able to convince him to let me in
which is a kind of positive polarity you
know but you're oblivious in the
situation but you could have got the
theme of denial of self which is in fact
what you did get right well I got in
though I had to pretend to be something
I'm not
you could have been yourself the entire
time and then super and been surprised
that the guard actually says great
welcome it's great to have a little
Sylvan flavor around here all right all
right yeah so you can have a number of
different kind of themes of vocht but by
the engine right yeah and just this is
on our site we built another another
system not all of our systems are our
games we build a kind of social
networking system
so something similar with your musical
identity categorizes you in terms of
your musical identity has BOTS that
speak to you your identity isn't an
avatar it's a photo wall that describes
your musical tastes and people kind of
push back what you said you like bebop
but in fact you really seem to like show
tunes now and this is the sort of thing
so anyhow remember me back from the
beginning of a talk yes so I'm moving
towards our conclusion
well phantasm is like this doctor main
implicit and invisible for users and
furthermore are implemented in back-end
data structures and algorithms which is
one of the key messages that I want you
to take home today so you can actually
sometimes very explicitly you know what
this is girl a boolean term in terms of
a key and the data structures whereas
this type of phantasms are
computationally modelled explicitly for
designing a design for studying cultural
meanings in digital media
yes sir which is again what I said that
we work on so to sum up I've introduced
an approach to computationally model to
computational modeling that I believe
provides powerful means of analyzing and
expressing cultural meanings such as
social identity phenomena focused on
today and my belief is that this
approach enables us to better understand
and convey cultural meanings that are
implemented throughout rhythms and data
structures in computational media and
finally apropos of the situation taking
the long view the idea is that of course
computing is now pervasive we all know
this but I believe is that the next
frontiers are computing must address the
issues of expression and culture there
are too often dismissed as being soft
with it within engineering at
disciplines in computing in fact what I
say is that these are the hard problems
as engineers like to put it to model to
model computationally and so I just want
to leave you with a message then that
it's imperative to reflect upon the
cultural values the subjective values
have that are built into the
infrastructures of this computer laying
late in society that we're all building
and living in together so thank you
[Applause]
thank you well we'll have a few minutes
for questions and then Fox is gonna
stick around as we like to do here he'll
be sticking around so you can talk to me
afterwards his book phantasmal media is
on the back table if you'd like to to
buy wine or check it out thank you so
much so before we get get your questions
ready but can you tell us for all the
different working on you know there's
more work than you had time to talk
about here in general how many people
here work in technology or in gaming or
anything like that so obviously you you
know the the area you're in we've got
that there they're working out of here
every day actually how much is the work
you're doing you're actually building
systems as well as doing these critiques
how much are they available that people
can use or look at what they're doing or
how much and where are you publishing
this stuff so that are those ideas all
right so you can so you could go to our
website this one I slabbed mit.edu yes
so there there's a projects page there
so you know a lot of our publications
are there some of the systems you can
use and play with you know so the social
network and user recommendation system
is there mimesis you could play that
play that game the system genie you know
that again I mentioned as a Creative
Commons license
if you're interested you could contact
me individually I'd be happy to make
that available so I've been contacted a
number of people in different areas you
know thinking about yeah I'm more
interested in kind of open-ended
expressive subjective tools but some
people are interested in issues like
diversity with it with in journalism and
responding to some of the social nuances
there and we're interested how can we
use mimesis to begin thinking these
issues through our more therapeutic uses
so I'm happy to see people push to push
the systems in new ways who's got a
question out there when the end of the
bar
so so about the gender you could select
it neverwinter nights right that's it's
a good question and very far from it an
attack it's I love the opportunity to
clarify yeah so with the city the system
it's it's interesting never went to
nights was hype for being a system that
actually tries to implement the
old-school pattern paper done to the
Dragon style gameplay for those who play
played or remember dungeons dragons from
the 80s and so they released released a
tool a tool set so people could create
ventures for for others so you can they
create the other characters non-player
characters yeah monsters you know sort
of set up the entire world and so that
data structure actually will be used
most likely for the non player
characters as well as other types of
creature in this case is fortunately we
have access to all of that on the
backend but the interesting thing is
that it's actually for the default to
racial types the types that player
characters can be the elves orcs have
works you are actually half-orcs humans
halflings and this sort of thing those
are the characters for which the type
that you can play you know that you're
gonna have a default male body type if
you set it as both other or none the
player can actually select the game
master can do it though
okay well I love this question because
you know the example I show you know I'm
a oriented toward a particular type of
empowerment but I'm actually interested
in is creating more expressive tools so
you can imagine there's onra fiction
authors they'll create a type of fiction
to comment on the real world do you
think about philip k dick Octavia Butler
the ideas these nuanced kind of
commentary about the real world often
dystopian not utopian are politically
correct and so the idea for me is I'd be
happy for people to create a game that's
a embeds racial profiling within the
game like Grand Theft Auto if it can
help to engender critical awareness
about about the system right rather than
this leaving it implicitly implemented
implemented within the system so the
idea for me is very far from the idea of
just creating didactic diversity
training tools but actually increasing
the expressive range so you can have
characters that respond to each other in
that one city that totally inverts the
politics of another city and begin to
have a lot more expressive power for
thinking about the for thinking about
these kinds of these kind of issues and
finally I would say that some of the
insights coming out of cognitive science
suggest that the way that these systems
typically categorize it's called a folk
or Aristotelian model of categories with
that means every category has some top
down some top down characteristics that
means if you are in this so in that if
you have this particular racial category
then you always have this kind of
attribute distribution and these
characteristics and look this way when
in the real world is much more nuanced
and in fluidity and so the idea is to
replace that very strict top-down system
that totally determines everything and
replaced it with one that actually
admits that kind of nuance and and
gradients and so then I think it's not
really a question of the algorithm just
defining that all people that are in
this group if you are this ethnicity
that means you can't jump but actually
having a system can make much more kind
of nuanced tops through observations at
least could be kind of phenomena that
can say there's a difference between a
salient example that means I've seen
three people that I can't jump in so I'm
gonna make a sumption and a stereotype
that means I'm building a misleading
assumption into my into my my example it
can make all these fine grained
distinctions between types of
categorization right there in a second
so you know all these games are you know
so you know you could solve that problem
right it's a good question I think
you're talking about two related kind of
issues because the question is about the
diversity of the industry in general and
so what increase in diversity increase
the possibility for diverse worldviews
and so of course there is a kind of
possibility there but of course
everybody exists within the society or
the same kind of the kind of worldviews
so one one point of the Kenneth mamie
Clarke study is that these kids are
there from you know they're
african-american students but still
exhibiting that that kind of worldview
right so that's just one part of the
issue actually for me when I talk about
culture computing in the book first
first that's just the issue of being
aware that all technical systems are
cultural systems they have values built
into them and so one day one of the
alumni of MIT AI lab the filigree did
some work that I was quite inspired by
what it was a theory that he calls
critical technical practices but means
engineers need to reflect critically
upon upon the kind of values that are
being built into into their systems in
some cases he traces failures of AI
systems to this exact issue and so I
would say first being aware of the
values that we're building into the into
the infrastructure themselves and that's
one thing that the idea that some of the
techniques in the book tried to provide
there's a concept called morphic
semiotics I described in chapter 4 and
then one of the one of the other kind of
issues is that engaging in diversity of
different worldviews might lend itself
to a different kind of innovative
practices but it's not just gonna I mean
of course it's great to fire or the
workforce in a number of different kind
of ways though economists have shown the
ways that this engenders new forms of
creativity and innovation and so forth
but it's not gonna fall out just be it
just because of any one individual
actually it's a kind of critical
practice that all of you designers have
to take part in and I think
one thing that might be a good
illustration is we talked about the the
eBay the way eBay sellers are recognized
especially when you map that back to
making a purchase from a merchant in the
real world you find that you have less
of the vocabularies or the the elements
that that seller is expressing their
their identity with are very limited
right yes okay I can I can I can tell
the story that happy to strive yes so
this is so everybody knows we're talking
about so this is the story of a bran yes
and it's a story of bran going to the
bazaar and so the idea here is that you
have this guy a bran that loves the shop
and he loves to buy right but he has a
particular set of preferences but he
thinks you can only trust a good man
when you buy he wants to see people
dressed in the adorned in the style of
his own clan he wants to see people have
good hygiene have other people walking
away with smiles and so forth there from
the seller and the question that you
raised is what happens when bran
encounters a seller that looks like this
all right and so what in fact happens
what - bran is this right he's just
confused no but the point that I raised
in the book is that even if you just
look at this aspect of the seller right
just the name and it's a star rating a
number rating you have a number of ways
that can be represented in the backend
right you could describe it in terms of
a string an integer and a gif file that
although using the term gif is
controversial these days since a creator
described as a jiff you could but you
can also describe as a matrix a some
number of pixels you could compare the
value of the feedback score much more
quickly so using integer we could
compare the saturation of the star and
better use it using this representation
but you can also have use this
representation how rightie they could
have implemented a maleness indicator a
hygiene indicator of facial hair
descriptor you know portraits of
previous buyers and video chat window
and so the point being that each of
these actually encodes a set of values
right the ebay one is much more familiar
to us we're accustomed to it but it's no
less evaluating that than the one that
Braun suggests and so again that's just
one example of critical technical
practice going back in and
the fact that this isn't a kind of
objective a cultural representation has
cultural values and maybe for good
reason based on user testing and so
forth but they're always built in the
system and in fact both represent a type
of phantasm that's great all right
we hope you'll hang out a bit longer
have a chance to speak with Fox directly
thanks again so much for coming out
tonight for being a part of this series
Fox this is a long now challenge coin I
want to give you the thank you for for
speaking to us for tonight I think it's
my pleasure and honor
[Applause]
[Music]